hello belief nation I started the mentum
e-series with the goal to try to hang
around people who've done a lot more
than us learn from their success soak in
a little bit more of their mindset and
beliefs and how they operate and you
know the environment is so important
that the more you can hang around these
people hopefully some of that seeps into
you to make you the best version of
yourself so today we're going to get
motivated with Sylvester Stallone mentor
me Sylvester what in this whole world
turns you on challenge I really just I
just love I love it you know I love
being told no it just means yes no to
you yeah what turned you off lack of
enthusiasm really turns me off like I
don't care what your grandfather thinks
about me okay all I care about is you
now you lost back there because you beat
yourself you let yourself get beat I
knew you can do it there's special kid
you're my boy do you understand but
you're also a spoiled rich brat who's
always had everything done for him now
it's time to do for yourself Mike and
you can do it because I'm telling you
the world meets nobody halfway do you
understand what that means if you want a
drink you gotta take it do you have it
you go in there and try I know you can
win but even if you don't so what so you
lose as long as you lose like a winner
it doesn't matter because you did it
with dignity I'm telling you if you
don't go in there you're gonna be sorry
you're gonna regret it your whole life
you know what I mean
come on no you can do it you do it for
me gone
it's kid let's start from the beginning
was there ever a time that you doubted
yourself yeah you know I thought when I
you know I lived in this basically as
flophouse its twenty six dollars a week
very transient and you shared a floor
with ten people you don't know anybody
on the planet literally know it I think
I recall you saying you're acting low
point The Godfather and you said you
couldn't even get into I couldn't be
your Casas in Italian I'll never forget
where there's a party seat is it three
hundred guests like a hug said no I go
what part of me didn't make pass the
Italian identification aspect to go I
don't know you just don't fit in God is
telling me something it's gonna play
with your psyche a little bit a little
bit no yeah but but it didn't and you
decided to take matters into your own
hands by writing yeah Rocky you know
I'll just coming in for six years six
years you've been sticking it to me I
wanted outcome no okay I'm gonna tell
you guys you like a time to become a
good fighter and instead of that you
became a raving you were able to write
rocky in three and a half days the movie
that went on to be best picture you
wrote in three and a half days yes was
it just flowing out of him anyway it was
I knew that this was going to be very
flawed but if I could get from the
beginning to the end with some semblance
of a character then I'll repair the rest
along the way and you want to star in it
and you're told no you mean you even
offer two hundred fifty thousand three
hundred and sixty Renison your
struggling actor who you you can't make
ends meet you can you're getting offered
all this money but you didn't take it no
I just didn't understand how the rules
of life were played at that point but
this character I understood what's your
point my point is I'm pursuing something
that nobody looks too happy about it
what we're just looking out for your
interests i apprec--
maybe you're looking out for your
interests just a little bit more I mean
you should be asking people to come down
here and pay the freight on something
they paid it still ain't good enough I
mean you think that's right I mean maybe
you're doing your job but why you gotta
stop me from doing mine because if
you're willing to go through all the
battle and you got to go through to get
to where you want to get who's got the
right to stop you I mean maybe some of
you guys got something you never
finished something you really want to do
something you never said to somebody
something and you're told no even after
you pay your dues who's got the right to
tell you that who no planning its your
right to listen to your gut and ain't
nobody's right to say no after you earn
right could be where you want to be a do
what you want to do you know the older I
get the more things I gotta leave behind
that's life the only thing I'm asking
you guys to leave on the table is what's
right I am a messenger I've always
believed that kind of a teacher
I've been down I've been poor I've I've
been the lowest person could be in this
business and come up so I've seen every
facet of it so don't ever the word
impossible should go out as I am a
living testimony that miracles do exist
through hard labor and dedication if I
had to rewind the clock ten years I
would have insisted by people that it
might close to me that please push me
into very unsafe process at least every
other one I think it's it's
professionally responsible to to not
continue to remake the same group over
Kentville what's tonight turkey TV
dinner turkey TV dinner Jimmy don't
think about this when you start and
treat me I'm not doing okie sir
not crazy at all if I could take
everything that was good and put it into
a bowl or something
and say hey here I'd like to buy one
more day with my wife I do it everything
I got is moved on and I'm here I never
wanted to do this movie I
a sick Rakhi is so counterintuitive to
what Rakhi really is designed for I just
lay that's akin someone else be sick in
the movie and not me because I've never
done that
my wife is your coward no one you know
it's kind of a harsh word he goes no no
it's your yellow basically you're a
coward it goes against every undeclared
artistic rule if you're afraid of
something that's the commitment of that
of the artist that's his duty to pursue
the unknown to go someplace where he's
literally at odds with himself right
there woman yeah you know if you look
hard enough you can see your whole life
will appear how does it look
he said he knew his whole life what he
want to do since he's very very young he
wanted to be in the movie business
period I mean not just TV movies and he
said why was for him it was a chance to
have people not only escape but to
inspire people and by the way that drive
is what made most of his movies inspired
people to what they're capable of
overcoming believable obstacles because
in his own life he felt like he did that
when he was born he's pulled out by the
forceps that's why he looked the way he
did that's why he talked to he did and
he said so I really want to do that and
he said I knew why I want to do it I
wasn't one to settle for anything else
and he said what happened was I went out
to try and get jobs and it's not like I
went her dream they want you you're a
star it didn't work out real well they
looked at me and said hey you're stupid
look and do something else you know with
cookie look is there's no place for you
in that stuff you're never gonna be a
star in the movies you're insane no
one's gonna wanna listen to somebody
looks Dobie and talks out of the side of
their mouth right and got no after no
after no after no he said I was thrown
out more fit more than 1,500 times of
agents offices in New York I said there
are 15-minute agents in New York I said
I know I've been on five six seven eight
nine times
he said number one guy went in there and
I got in there at four o'clock and he
wouldn't see me so I stayed there and I
would not leave I stayed overnight they
came back next morning I'm still sitting
there he's that's why I got my first job
the guy said point come in here and he
sat down and he went through this and he
gave my first movie so really I thought
locky first mom he said now this other
movie I never heard of it he said I said
well what character you play so I was in
it for about 20 seconds I was a thug
somebody beat up he said because they
made me feel like you know some of the
people hate your guts you getting beat
up it'll be a good thing and he did like
three movies like that never got
anything kept going out rejection
rejection rejection so finally realized
it wasn't working so he changed his
approach he said I was starving by the
way he said I couldn't pay for even to
have heat in my apartment my wife was
screaming at me everyday to go get a job
I said well why didn't you
he said cuz I knew that if I got a job
he said I'd get seduced back and I'd
lose my hunger he said I knew the only
way I could do this is if it was the
only choice if I burned all of the
bridges because if I did a normal job
pretty soon I'd be caught up in that
rhythm
that stuff when I feel okay about my
life and I feel like my dream would just
gradually disappear he said I wanted to
keep that hunger that hunger was the
only thing I thought was my advantage he
said my wife didn't understand that at
all
he said we have these vicious fights he
said it was freezing so I was broke we
had no money and he said so I finally
went to the public library one day
because it was warm so I don't want to
read anything since I went in New York
Public Library I was hanging out there
and I sat on this chair and somebody
left a book there and he said I looked
at this book and over the poems of Edgar
Allan stories of Edgar Allan Poe and he
said so I started reading it he said I
got totally in the other growlin polity
so I know everything about it he goes on
for another 20 minutes tell me about it
girl he knows everything how he died
what it was about what really happened I
said well would have Poe do for you he
said Poe got me out of myself
he got me to think about how I could
touch other people not worry about
myself so much and he said maybe decide
to become a writer I said just imagine
Rocky the writer right and he said so I
tried to write a bunch of screenplays
nothing work nothing to work I were
totally broke he said I didn't even have
fifty bucks and he said and finally he
said I sold a script it was called
paradise alleys as a movie I made many
years later but I sold it he said I sold
it for a hundred bucks he said but a
hundred bucks was a ton of money man I
was so thrilled I thought I'm on my way
but it never led to anything he said so
finally he said I kept going and going
going he said finally we were so broke
he said i hocked my wife's jewelry he
said Tony there's some things in life
you should never do he said that was
basically the end of our relationship
she hated my guts so much
he said now we were so broke we had
nothing no food no money and he said the
one thing I love most in the world was
my dog he said I love my dog because he
gave me unconditional love unlike my
wife and he said so what happened was
though we were so broke good to survive
I couldn't even feed my dog so I went to
a liquor stores there was the lowest day
of my life and I stood outside the
liquor store trying to sell my dog to
strangers so I tried to sell my dog for
50 bucks
and he said this finally there's one guy
negotiated with me and bought my dog for
me my best friend and ours for $25
he said I walked away from there and I
cried he says the worst thing that ever
happened in my life he's a two weeks
later I'm watching a fight between
Muhammad Ali and Wepner this white guy
that's getting bludgeoned but just keeps
on coming
and he said I got an idea he said as
soon as the fight ended I started
writing he said I wrote for 20 straight
hours I did not sleep I wrote the entire
movie in 20 hours straight right then
saw the fight wrote the movie whole
thing done he said I was shaking at the
end I was so excited so I really knew
man I knew what I wanted I knew why I
wanted he said just like you teach that
formula he said but I said man I took
the action now it's time to deliver and
so he said I went out started trying to
sell it to agents and they all would
read it they'd say you know this is
predictable
this is stupid this is sappy he said I
wrote down all the things they said and
I read them the night of the Oscars when
we want is really good right the
greatest revenge is massive success they
said so what happened was he said I kept
going trying to sell it trying to sell
it nobody going I'm broke I'm starving
he said finally I meet these guys they
read it and they believed in the script
and they love it and they offer me a
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
from my script I said oh my god you must
been out of your mind he said I was I
said just one thing though guys you got
a deal based on one thing they said
what's that he said I got a star in it
they went what are you talking about
you're a writer so no I'm an actor
there's no no you're a writer so no no
I'm an actor that is my story and I am
rocky said I got to play it you know I
got to be the head person I got me the
starring role this there's no way when I
can pay hundred twenty-five thousand
dollars take some no-name and stick you
in that throw our money away we need a
star you know and they want to have Ryan
O'Neal play Rocky give you a picture can
you imagine
that's who they picked right and so he
said no way Ryan O'Neal's and Rocky I'm
rocky went to this whole thing right
they finally he said they said we'll
take it or leave it he said I left the
room I said if that's what you believe
you know get my script he left here's
the man with no money
none totally broke offered $125,000 more
money in his lifetime he walked away
because he knew his real what knew his
real life and why I wanted he was
committed to it so he said they called
him a few weeks later and they came he
brought it back and they offered him a
quarter of a million dollars not to star
in his own movie
he turned it down $250,000 they came
back their final offers three hundred
and twenty five thousand dollars they
wanted this thing he said not without me
and they said no they finally
compromised and they gave him thirty
five thousand dollars and points in the
movie because I said if this is going to
happen then you're going to take the
risk with us and the bottom line is we
don't think it will work but at least we
won't spend a bunch of money on you and
they only spent a million dollars to
make Rocky and it grows 200 million
dollars at the time it was done pretty
well but what's interesting about this
is here's he I said what you do mean
even 35,000 it's not a quarter of a
million that's a lot of money when you
don't have 25 bucks I said what's the
first thing you did I figure you went
out and partied or something said I went
to that liquor store for three straight
days and hope that the man had my dog
frequented the store
because I want to buy back my dog that
was so cool right that was really cool I
said what happened he said third day I
was there this guy walks by and I see
him I can't believe it there's my dog
and I looked at her I said sir remember
me and he said it's been about a month
and a half I thought this would all come
about he said member me and I'm the guy
who sold you the dog I go yeah yeah I
love the dog he said look he said I was
so broke I was starving he's my best
friend I'm sure you loved him too but I
gotta happen black please I beg of you
he's all people hundred dollars to the
dog I know he paid me 25 I'll give you
100 the man said absolutely not no way
he's my dog now you can't buy him back
right and so I said you know Tony you
know they say no you're out come I said
yeah he said I knew it and he said I
kept changing my approach so I went $500
for the dog the guy said absolutely no
way he said $1,000 for my dog guy said
no amount of money nervous then we're
gonna get this dog for you
so what'd you do he said I knew my
outcome right because he listened the
same skip to him he says I take massive
action he said I got my dog I just kept
changing my approach so I got it as a
what it cost you fifteen thousand
dollars and a part in Rocky
the guys in Rocky
either that dog in rocky but kiss that
slice real dog right that's the dog he
bought a bank so he put his dog in the
movie and he put the guy in the movie
paid 15 grand well he had 35,000 not
pretty cool pretty awesome
so there's always a way if you're
committed just kind of keep changing
your brunch but somewhere along the line
you changed you stopped being you you
let people stick a finger in your face
and tell you you're no good and when
things got hard you started looking for
something to blame like a big shadow let
me tell you something you already know
the world ain't all sunshine and
rainbows it's a very mean and nasty
place and I don't care how tough you are
it will beat you to your knees and keep
you there permanently if you let it you
me or nobody is gonna hit as hard as
life but it ain't about how hard you hit
it's about how hard you can get hit and
keep moving forward how much you can
take and keep moving forward that's how
weird it is done now if you know what
you're worth the glottic guilt what
you're worth but you got to be willing
to take the hits and not pointing
fingers saying you ain't where you wanna
be because of him or her or anybody
cowards do that in that ain't you you're
better than that thank you guys so much
for watching I'd love to know what did
you think of this video what kind of
motivation did you get from it what was
your favorite clip and why leave it down
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you again for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon